[MUSIC PLAYING]
JASON SILVA: Now I'm
fascinated by airplanes.
Aviation is an
engineering miracle,
a form of divine engineering.
Alain de Botton
beautifully talked
about the awe-inspiring
rapture one
feels when one bears witness
to the power of a jet engine,
to the power of
a flying machine.
And I remember the first I
saw the A380 this hit me home.
But Alain de Botton
says nothing prepares
you or the sense of
agility and self-possession
of a jet airplane.
No structure of compare
the size-- a building
or a cathedral-- can compare
to that feeling of freedom,
of exhilaration that
machine promises.
He talks about walking through
a corridor that will lead you
onto a craft that will
take you somewhere
where no one knows your name.
It becomes a kind of
ontological journey.
It becomes a journey
of self-realization,
of soaring above ones limits.
The jet airplane
literalizes the human goal
of transcending our limitation.
It's always a symbolic journey.
Airlines don't realize this.
People talk about how the
enchantment of flying,
the magic of flying, has faded.
And people are so bored.
Because they're
closing their windows.
They're afraid to look out.
They're afraid to bear
witness to what is possible.
Look at the appeal of those
screens in the airports
with the promise of destinations
of spaces of happiness,
places where the
answers might lie.
Alain de Botton
beautifully talks about it.
Thing of the imaginative
allure or Paris,
of Amsterdam, of the Czech
Republic, of Cape Town.
On my god these places sing.
They sing to us.
They beckon.
This is the power of these
transcendent machines.
And we need to just open
our eyes a little bit.
This is a daily reminder
every day of what's possible.
This is who we are.
These are our technological
skins, our scaffoldings.
We have wings, people.
We may be flawed
stumbling primates.
But when we work together we
are primates that can fly.
Hey guys, you want to take
a look at Shots of Awe
behind the scenes, how
it all comes to life?
Well then check
out this episode I
shot on Seeker Stories, which
explores my daily rituals
and how we make Shots of Awe.